[Music]
students come in with opinions already
and they can say things in a seminar
that are based upon just
their common knowledge and not based on
the readings
today on chalk radio we're exploring
global food production water and climate
change
and the challenge of teaching when
polarized opinions come to class
i'd say generally the students learn
that most of these issues are more
subtle and complex than they thought
when they came in the class
so
one of the things that happens at the
end of the class is people's opinions
are usually not as
polarized as they were in the beginning
i'm kurt newton your guest host for this
episode of chalk radio at mit
officially i'm director of mit
opencourseware but for so many years at
mit and in my personal life
i'm also doing a lot of work on climate
change
so when sarah hansen your usual host
lined up this episode dealing with these
issues that are so deeply personal for
me around climate change food systems
and water
and gave me the chance to join in i
jumped at it
with prolonged droughts made worse by
climate change affecting food production
and ecosystems all around the world
this conversation couldn't be more
timely our guest dennis mclaughlin is a
professor in mit's civil and
environmental engineering department and
he's the instructor for course 1.74 land
water food and climate
professor mclaughlin's interest in
hydrology and what it can tell us about
our food systems has been years in the
making
it all started back in 1991
on a research trip that took him halfway
around the world
i went to australia
and there were a lot of discussions at
the time about what was sustainable
food production and whether or not
australia could grow more food with
limited water
and the connection between the
availability water and the population
and food supply
struck me as a really interesting
application area for hydrology
dennis explained that some of the big
wheat growing areas were becoming
reliant on irrigation to supplement
natural rainfall with water pumped from
underground in order to keep the crop
big and healthy
but over time
all that irrigation causes salts to
build up in the soil
you could go out in the fields and see
near the irrigation ditches just white
layers of salt accumulating it's the
same kind of problem that
ruined mesopotamian civilization you
know millennia ago and it wasn't like it
was a big surprise
but there was not really a good
mechanism to encourage farmers to
hold back on their irrigation
there was a lot of interest in
changing regulations and incentives for
farmers to have less adverse
environmental impact especially with
salinity
and to make sure that there was enough
water to keep the agriculture economy
healthy and going
i mean it's not a reasonable solution to
say we won't have any more farming and
therefore we won't have salt
accumulation and so on so it's that
balance between
sustainable use and economically
productive use that's tricky
this experience in australia led to the
creation of a course on water usage and
agriculture and food systems
it was here where professor mclaughlin
recognized that teaching these topics
can bring about an extra challenge
one of the interesting things about the
course and a challenging thing as a
teacher is a lot of the topics we talk
about sort of like talking about climate
change rgmos
our food waste our
vegetarianism
students come in with opinions already
and they can say things in a seminar
that are based upon just their common
knowledge and not based on the readings
so for example in gmos
the focus of most of the students is oh
gmos hurt me human health are they going
to cause me to have cancer or
whatever
and that's really not the scientific
perspective so much in gmos because
there's almost zero evidence that any
gmos are harmful to human health
and they learn that by reading the
papers
the problem is what do they do to the
ecosystem and what do they do to other
plants that are not genetically
manipulated and what are the unintended
consequences of gmos because gmos are
generally
designed to
help the farmer be more productive
one of the things that happens at the
end of the class is people's opinions
are usually not as
polarized as they were in the beginning
in my own work on climate change i've
certainly had this experience of
trying to have conversations with people
coming out of polarized opinions and
preconceived notions
i was really curious to hear how dennis
moved beyond that in this class and
helped the students have more productive
conversations view these sometimes
controversial issues from multiple
angles
it's really just an introductory course
and it's to kind of stimulate interest
that they had when they came in
and show them that it is possible to
pursue difficult topics by going to the
literature many of them aren't used to
reading scientific papers the
undergraduates especially they're used
to being lectured to and things being in
textbooks
and here's where dennis mclaughlin gets
creative
for each article he assigns a student is
asked to present that article to the
class
but
dennis also gives a specific prompt to
make sure that these presentations
actually help the students understand
the material
another challenge in the course is to
make sure that their presentations don't
bore the other students
so
i said you just have a minute or two and
you should pose some questions for the
class or some issues and make them as
controversial as possible so that's
that's what we try to do
as controversial as possible
wouldn't encouraging controversy just
prevent us from moving beyond polarized
opinions
dennis went on to explain
why controversy really is productive and
important to deal with especially in
science and engineering classrooms
another thing they're not used to the
students
even some of the graduate students is
scientific controversy
there's perhaps not that much
controversy ironically interestingly
about gmos
but there's a lot of controversy about
things like organic farming
and whether or not we should be willing
to sacrifice yield a bit to have more
sustainable agriculture
and one of the things we find out in the
class is many people who are
organic farming advocates
are
sort of out of the mainstream of the
scientific literature
but when you
review the papers on the other side that
say
for example
it's silly to try to continue
smallholder farming in africa
africa's agricultural future should be
large industrial farms
perhaps run by foreigners
who buy or lease the land
so people write
assessments like that and you say well
yeah but they're being funded by the
large agricultural industry
well does that mean they're wrong are
they biased well i don't know
but they become advocates too
so the students read the papers and we
try to discuss
both sides of an argument uh based on
the merits
and um
i'm not saying students don't get
exposure to that kind of thing elsewhere
but if they're taking physics and we're
talking about
newton's law you know it's not presented
as
a controversy
motivating students to engage with the
scientific literature to unpack
controversies is only part of the work
involved in teaching this engineering
course
there's something else too
something really important
it's a challenge to decide how much
effort and
discussion to spend on learning
about scientific issues scientific
controversies
more or less agreed on facts
and how much to spend on things like
values because
you really can't talk about smallholder
farming unless you talk about poverty
you can ask questions so why is the
smallholder farmer so poor why does the
smallholders kids not want to stay on
the farm they want to go to the city
what do they do in the city are there
jobs there
well do they have any education
well no because the smallholder farmer
doesn't have enough money
to send the child to school
what about the role women in farming and
the role of cultural differences in how
women are viewed and can they for
example participate in ownership
you could just spend the whole semester
talking about this stuff
dennis's course attracts students from a
wide variety of disciplines and
backgrounds
and it's this diversity of experiences
among the students that enriches the
class for everyone including dennis
i had a student in the last class who
was
an art student at mass college of art
and she knew almost nothing about
engineering or science but she came from
venezuela and settled in puerto rico and
her aunt is a farmer
and so she talked about how hard it was
for puerto rican farmers to be competing
with central american farmers who were
very poor who were exporting produce to
puerto rico so puerto rico this place
where you can grow food all the time
this
very productive climate
is
not producing much food for its own
residents because of pricing and she
actually brought that to the class and
talked about it and i i wouldn't even
thought about it so there's this
interaction between the students who
have had
farming experience or just
a student from puerto rico who's talking
to one from philadelphia and they're
both from cities
but they have a much different
perspective
so not only did the other students learn
from these students but i learned from
them
as you may have picked up by now climate
change is an important topic in this
course
we asked dennis how climate change will
affect food and agriculture
well that sounds like a question we
could pose in the class and we do
discuss it through reading papers
so this is a big topic and a controversy
one um one thing that there seems to be
pretty good agreement on is if climate
change
increases temperatures during the
growing season sufficiently that will
hurt
agriculture but it depends on the crop
depends on the place
it's a lot different talking about small
increases in average temperature
versus large increases
that could actually reduce yield or even
kill crops
so temperature extremes probably won't
help
this course really pushes its
participants to look beyond their own
assumptions
questions contradictions uncertainties
those are inevitable when we take on
topics as complex as food water and
climate change
professor mclaughlin embraces that
questioning as a core part of the class
even as he tries to provide some answers
especially undergrads they're used to
going into class and thinking they're
learning quote facts and that's the end
of the story but
i view the teacher as kind of adjusting
resetting the discussion
to keep things kind of on track and
consistent with the papers
but giving the students
the freedom to say silly things or to go
beyond the scope of the paper is part of
why they like the course
when they learn that their differences
of opinion even among experts and that
their values value judgments and that
their
social equity and all kinds of things
and
i can't i you know
they don't even connect that really with
formal education
but it's not so easy because for one
thing it takes the students off balance
a bit
so it's definitely an art and you learn
it over multiple times you can't just
start the very first year and be perfect
on it so you have to learn the teaching
style
as well as the content you have to teach
yourself how to be observant to what
works and what doesn't
[Music]
maybe we can all take a page or two from
professor mclaughlin and his students
get a little more comfortable being
knocked off balance
dennis's perspective made me wonder how
other educators handle similar
situations
how do you integrate conversations about
values and culture into your science and
engineering courses in a way that feels
balanced
you can share your insights via the link
in the show notes and we'll pass them
along to mit faculty and listeners who
could incorporate your ideas into their
teaching
[Music]
if you're interested in learning more
about professor mclaughlin's work or
teaching with his open educational
resources
you can check out his course 1.74 land
water food and climate on our mit open
courseware website
it's one of over 150 courses
in ocw's extensive environment courses
collection
and for even more check out the mit
climate website at
climate.mit.edu where you'll find a
wealth of material spanning these topics
and more thank you so much for listening
until next time signing off from
cambridge massachusetts i'm kurt newton
from mit open courseware
chalk radio's producers include sarah
hansen brett pachi and dave lachansky
scriptwriting assistance from nidhi
sastry
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you